يضع يده في يد الصين فهل حان وقت الخيانه
وبعد عاصفه تهديدات النوويه من بدايه
الحرب الاوكرانيه
يطمئن العالم وقطاع الدفاع الامريكي في
موقف محرج فما هو السبب الولايات المتحده
تعترف بقوه الدب الروسي وتحذر من كارثه
خلال الايام القادمه والاسلحه الغربيه تضع
الجيش الاوكراني في موقف المخزن والصين
لامريكا لا ننصحك باللعبه مع الزعيم كوريا
الشماليه وواشنطن ترد عسكريا بالمشاركه مع
حلفائها والحرب السودانيه تتوسع وهدنه
خامسه وعداد الضحايا لا يتوقف جيش الكيان
يقتحم جنين
يتلاعب باعصاب بايدن
القطه الروسيه يزداد ثقلها
تراجع كبير على الارض واحشاء المخازن
الاوكرانيه خاويه والمعارك تستعر ولكن
هناك تشمر عن ساعدها وتفكر بتوجيه ضربه من
نوع اخر وليس الهدف هذه المره روسيا بل
الولايات المتحده وذلك بعد ان دخلت الصين
على خط الوساطه بين روسيا واوكرانيا
لايجاد ارضيه للمفاوضات وارساء الهدنه
ولكني الى تلك اللحظه فكل شيء كان يمضي
بطريقه طبيعيه حتى جاء الامر الغريب بل
والاكثر غرابا الذي صدر من الرئيس
الاوكراني حيث اكد لنظيره الصيني بان
اوكرانيا تؤمن بمبدا الصين الواحده في
طعنه قويه لوشنطن في جسد القضيه
التايوانيه واضف علي ان الرئيس الاوكراني
قد وفق مبدئيا على اتفاقيه الصين حيث
ارسلت سفيرا للصين من اجل مناقشه هذا
الاتفاق الذي وصفه بالمثمر نحن لم ناتي
بشيء من رؤوسنا اليكم المصدر وان الرئيس
فلاديمير زيلينسكي وصفه بالمثمر والبناء
ووصف ايضا تعيين السفير السفير اوكرانيا
في الصين اي بدفعه جديده في نحو العلاقات
الثنائيه بين اوكرانيا
اذا كيف سيرد الغربيون على كييف الحرب
تستعر والاسلحه الغربيه التي تصل لك تضع
القوات الاوكرانيه في موقف محرج وذلك بسبب
كثره الاعطال ما يجعلها غير قادره على
منافسه الاسلحه الروسيه مثل مقاتله
التي وصلت من بولندا وسلوفاكيا للقوات
الاوكرانيه حيث ان مقاتله موسكو مجهزه
بانظمه رادار وصواريخ متطوره جدا بينما
الطائرات الاوكرانيه
جدا بكل اختصار ووضوح ايهما اسرع السياره
القديمه ام الفرار الحديثه وذلك وفق صحيفه
واشنطن بوست فمن سيدفع اذا خساره نقل هذه
الطائرات واصلاحها يا هؤلاء لتجيبك بنفسها
وذلك باعلان الحكومه الاوكرانيه تلقيها
دفعه من منحه المساعدات الامريكيه
والبالغه مليارا 250 مليون دولار لصالح
ميزانيه الدوله الاوكرانيه لضمان استمرار
عمل الدوله في البلاد بحسب وكاله تاس
لتواصل الكفه ميلانها نحو الدب الروسي حيث
كشفت المخابرات الامريكيه ان روسيا قادره
على تمويل الحرب في اوكرانيا لمده عام اخر
على الاقل حتى في ظل العبء الثقيل
والمتزايد للعقوبات غير المسبوقه وفقا
للوثائق الامريكيه المسربه التي نشرتها
صحيفه
ومع رجحان كافه موسكو كافه واشنطن حيث
يعيش قطاع الدفاع الامريكي في موقف حرج
عسكريا وذلك بسبب انفجار مصنع الباروتي من
جن عام 2021 فضلا عن مساعدات الولايات
المتحده العسكريه لاوكرانيا التي جعلت
مخزون الاسلحه والقذاء في الامريكي ينفذ
وذلك بحسب صحيفه بوليس وبينما يضع العالم
يده على قلبه تاتي الطمانينه من الجانب
الروسي هذه المره وليس لامريكا فقط بل
للعالم اجمع حين اعلن الكرملين انه يرحب
باي محاوله من اي طرف كان من صديق او عدو
يهدف لانهاء الصراع الاوكراني ولكن بشروط
موسكو الطمانه الروسيه لم تنتهي بعد عقب
عده تهديدات باستخدام السلاح النووي او
الكرملين يتراجع حيث قال الكرملين في
تصريحات صحفيه نقلت وسائل اعلام روسيه ان
جميع الاطراف تواصل الالتزام بوقف هذه
التجارب الانتهاء بذلك خطر الحرب العالميه
ام ان للولايات المتحده رايا اخر ومن
التهدئه الروسيه الى واقع الحرب
الاوكرانيه حيث انطلقت سفاره الانذار في
انحاء مختلفه من اوكرانيا وقالت السلطات
الاوكرانيه ان روسيا اطلقت اكثر من عشرين
صاروخ كروز طائرتين من دون طيار على كييف
واجزاء اخرى من اوكرانيا لتعلن وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تصفيه اكثر من 500
جنديا الاوكرانيا على كافه المحاور بينما
لقي حوالي 20 ضابطا رفيع المستوى بينهم
اجانب مصرعهم بعد استهداف المقر الذي
كانوا يجتمعون فيه بصاروخ في حوض بناء
السفن بمقاطعه
ومن المعارك في اوكرانيا الى حرب السياسيه
والدبلوماسيه حيث عزل الروسي نائب وزير
الدفاع الروسي الفريق اول ميخائيل
الملقب بجزار من منصبه فيما اشار التقارير
الى ان ذلك نتيجه نفاذ صبره من استمرار
الفشل وعدم تحقيق اي نتائج ايجابيه في
الحرب الاوكرانيه بحسب وكاله رويترز وهنا
قالها بوتين صراحه بان قيم الخدمه المكرسه
للناس والوطن تحدد قوه واستقرار الدوله
وتؤكد وحده وتماسك الشعب وان روسيا ستمضي
للامام فقط نحو اهدافها العليا المحدده
وعلى صيد السياسه الروسيه وبعد ان اقتربت
موسكو من تعليق اتفاق الحبوب قال وزير
الخارجيه التركي مولود شاوغلو ان
المشاركين في صفقه الحبوب لم يلتزموا بما
وعدوا به روسيا فهل هي رساله من بوتين على
لسان الاتراك كوريا الشماليه والعداوه
الامريكيه رغم كثره اعداء الولايات
فان كوريا الشماليه تبقى عدوا خاصا
للامريكان ليجتمع الرئيس الامريكي بنظيره
الكوري الجنوبي وهناك توصل الجانبان الى
اتفاق جديد يتضمن خططا لنشر غواصه نوويه
امريكيه في كوريا الجنوبيه للمساعده في
ردع اي هجمات تقوم بها جارتها وتقصد كوريا
الشماليه وذلك ضمن الاتفاق الذي اطلق عليه
اعلان واشنطن فكيف سيرد الزعيم كوريا
الشماليه الرد جاء فعلا ولكن على لسان
التنين الصيني حيث وجهت الصين تحذيرا
شديدا لهجه الى كل من امريكا وكوريا
الجنوبيه من مغبه اثاره مواجهات مع كوريا
الشماليه بعدما قال الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن ونظيره الكوري الجنوبي ان اي هجوم
نووي تطلقه كوريا الشماليه سيفضي الى
نهايه نظامها كان ذلك
صينيا صريحا فهل فهمه الامريكانو يا ترى
دائره الحرب السودانيه تتسع
القتال يتواصل والمعارك تمتد والخراب
يتوسع والضحايا في ازدياد يا ساده ليعلن
الطرفان من قوه الدعم السريع وقوات الجيش
عن هدنه خامسه على التوالي ويا لها من
هدنه لم يكد حبر ورقيا يجف حتى اندلعت
الاشتباكات في عدد من المدن السودانيه وفي
مقدمتها العاصمه الخرطوم وها هو القتال
يمتد حتى وصل الى منطقه الجنينه غربيه
اقليم دارفور ليستحضر السودانيون تلك
الرقعه من بلادهم التي لطالما كانت مسرحا
بصراعات بين الجماعات المسلحه والحكومه
والى حد اللحظه سقط في دارفور فقط 74
قتيلا خلال يومين بحسب وكاله الانباء
الفرنسيه فهل تعود ماسيدرفور على من جديد
من جهه اخرى يرفض الجيش السوداني الدخول
في اي تفوض مع قياده قوات الدعم السريع
ويصمم على انهاء المعركه في وقت تزداد فيه
تكاليف الحرب التي ليس هناك منها من مفر
ومع هذه الظروف الامنيه المعقده تستمر
عمليه اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب من العاصمه
الخرطوم
الاحداث والتطورات سخر الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب من الرئيس جو بايدن
الذي اعلن ترشحه لولايه جديده عبر التقليد
بايدن وتصويره على انه يعاني من الخرف
ويفتقر الى الطاقه اقتحم الجيش الاسرائيلي
مخيم جنين في الضفه الغربيه المحتله من
محاور عده وسط اشتباكات مسلحه مع
فلسطينيين براتب 155 الف دولار اعلن عمده
اول قيصر الفئران في نيويورك كجزء من جهود
ارمز لمكافحه تزايد اعداد القوارض في
المدينه الاكثر اكتظاظا بالسكان في
المقاطعه بعد ان وضع العلم يده على قلبه
خوفا من حرب النوويه جاء بوتين ليعلنها
للعالم بانه ليس هناك خطر لحرب
فهلان للعالم ان يطمئن ولو قليلا
[موسيقى]